Welcome back to your Danish citizenship exam companion.
This is Chapter Four, Episode Two: Denmark and the EU, and the Danish opt-outs.
What happens when Denmark hands some of its decision-making power to Brussels?
On certain areas, the EU has gained access to adopt legislation which the Folketing would otherwise adopt.
The EU has, for example, access to adopt rules that remove trade barriers between the member countries.
With its membership of the EU, Denmark has thus given up some of its right of self-determination.
The Danish constitution makes that possible.
But quite strict requirements are set for making such a decision.
At least five sixths, that is at least 150, of the Folketing's 179 members must say yes to Denmark's participation in the international cooperation, if it means Denmark gives up national self-determination.
If fewer than 150 members, but still a simple majority of 90, say yes, a referendum must be held on whether Denmark is to take part in the international cooperation.
Even though opinion polls show that the population is overwhelmingly positive about EU membership, it has often been divided in its attitude to whether the EU should cover more policy areas, and whether Denmark should abolish its EU opt-outs.
From the time the Danes said yes to membership of the EF in 1972, nine referendums have been held on changes in the cooperation.
Six times a majority of the voters have voted yes.
Three times a majority has voted no.
The Danes voted yes to membership of the EF in a referendum in 1972, and Denmark became a member in 1973.
Since the constitution of 1953, more referendums have been held about Denmark's relationship with the EU than about any other subject, more than about the constitution or the voting age.
That last point comes from what the exams ask, rather than from the textbook text.
Now, the Danish EU opt-outs, forbehold.
A crucial vote where the Danish population voted no was at the referendum on the Maastricht Treaty in 1992.
Denmark then got a special agreement with the other EU countries.
The special agreement is known as the Edinburgh Agreement.
It means that there are parts of the EU cooperation which Denmark does not take part in.
The agreement is also called "the four opt-outs".
The agreement was sent to a referendum the year after, in 1993.
This time a majority of Danes voted yes to the Maastricht Treaty with the following four EU opt-outs: union citizenship, the common currency, the euro, the defence area, and a common justice and immigration policy, the justice opt-out, retsforbeholdet.
The justice opt-out means that Denmark does not take part in cooperation in a number of legal areas, for example the common immigration and asylum policy and police work on cross-border crime.
In 2015 there was a referendum on whether the justice opt-out should be converted into an opt-in arrangement, a tilvalgsordning.
The opt-in arrangement would give Denmark the possibility of itself deciding which parts of the legal EU cooperation Denmark wants to take part in, but at the same time the possibility of choosing to stay outside other areas.
At the referendum in 2015, the Danes voted no to converting the justice opt-out.
Denmark therefore does not take part in the cooperation with the other EU countries in most legal areas, including the areas mentioned above.
Next, the euro.
The opt-out on the common currency means that Denmark is not obliged to introduce the euro.
In 2000 there was a referendum where the population was to decide whether they wanted to lift the opt-out and thereby introduce the euro in Denmark.
53.2 percent of Danes voted no to this proposal, and 46.8 percent voted yes.
Despite Denmark having a euro opt-out, Denmark still takes part in parts of the euro cooperation.
For example, Denmark follows a so-called fixed exchange rate policy, which means that the rate of the Danish krone follows the rate of the euro, so that you can always buy 1 euro for about 7.50 Danish kroner.
Likewise Denmark follows interest rate rises or cuts from the European Central Bank.
Then, defence.
Previously Denmark also had an opt-out on the EU's defence and security policy, so Denmark, for example, did not take part in military operations that are part of the EU cooperation.
This so-called defence opt-out was lifted as a result of a referendum on the first of June, 2022.
A majority of 66.9 percent voted yes to lifting the opt-out, while a minority of 33.1 percent voted no.
So today Denmark has no defence opt-out, and does take part in the EU's defence and security policy.
And finally, union citizenship.
Denmark's opt-out on union citizenship was introduced to guarantee that union citizenship should not develop into something on a par with national citizenship or completely replace it.
With the Amsterdam Treaty coming into force in 1999, this came to apply to all member countries.
Therefore this Danish EU opt-out is also no longer relevant.
So of the four opt-outs from 1993, two still apply: the euro opt-out, and the justice opt-out.
The defence opt-out was abolished in 2022, and the union citizenship opt-out is no longer relevant.
Here is your recap for Episode Two.
To give up national self-determination, at least 150 of the 179 members of the Folketing must say yes; if fewer than 150, but at least 90, say yes, there must be a referendum.
Since 1972, nine referendums on changes to the cooperation: six yes, three no.
In 1992, Denmark voted no to the Maastricht Treaty, which led to the Edinburgh Agreement and the four opt-outs.
In 1993, Denmark voted yes with the opt-outs.
The four were union citizenship, the euro, defence, and justice.
In 2000, 53.2 percent voted no to the euro.
About 7.50 kroner buys one euro, the fixed exchange rate.
In 2015, Denmark voted no to converting the justice opt-out.
On the first of June, 2022, 66.9 percent voted yes to abolishing the defence opt-out.
Union citizenship is no longer relevant since 1999.
Two opt-outs still apply: the euro and justice.
Warning: older exams asked about a Danish defence opt-out.
That was true until the first of June 2022, so if an option says defence, it is outdated.
And the exams also ask this: Greenland and the Faroe Islands are part of the Danish Realm, but they are not part of the EU.
Now it is time for your exam practice.
These are real questions from past Danish citizenship exams on what you just heard.
For each one, I will read the question and the choices, then pause so you can pick your answer, and then I will give you the correct answer.
Question 1.
What was a referendum held about in 1972?
Option A: Denmark's entry into the EF.
Option B: Denmark's entry into NATO.
Option C: Denmark's entry into the UN.
[DA] Hvad blev der afholdt en folkeafstemning om i 1972?  A: Danmarks indtræden i EF  |  B: Danmarks indtræden i NATO  |  C: Danmarks indtræden i FN
The answer is A: Denmark's entry into the EF.
It appeared in 4 different exams, most recently in June 2026.
[DA] ✔ A: Danmarks indtræden i EF
Question 2.
Which subject has been the subject of the most referendums in Denmark since 1953?
Option A: The constitution.
Option B: The voting age.
Option C: Denmark's relationship to the EU.
[DA] Hvilket emne har der været afholdt flest folkeafstemninger om i Danmark siden 1953?  A: Grundloven  |  B: Valgretsalderen  |  C: Danmarks forhold til EU
The answer is C: Denmark's relationship to the EU.
It appeared in the May 2023 and May 2025 exams.
[DA] ✔ C: Danmarks forhold til EU
Question 3.
Which of the Danish EU opt-outs was the subject of a referendum in 2022?
Option A: The EU's common currency, the euro.
Option B: The EU's common justice and immigration policy.
Option C: The EU's defence and security policy.
[DA] Hvilket af de danske EU-forbehold var der folkeafstemning om i 2022?  A: EU's fælles valuta (euroen)  |  B: EU's fælles rets- og udlændingepolitik  |  C: EU's forsvars- og sikkerhedspolitik
The answer is C: The EU's defence and security policy.
It appeared in the May 2024 exam.
[DA] ✔ C: EU's forsvars- og sikkerhedspolitik
Question 4.
Does Denmark take part in the EU's defence and security policy?
Option A: Yes.
Option B: No.
[DA] Deltager Danmark i EU’s forsvars- og sikkerhedspolitik?  A: Ja  |  B: Nej
The answer is A: Yes.
It appeared in the November 2022 exam.
[DA] ✔ A: Ja
Question 5.
Does Denmark have an opt-out on the EU's defence and security policy?
Option A: Yes.
Option B: No.
[DA] Har Danmark forbehold for EU’s forsvars- og sikkerhedspolitik?  A: Ja  |  B: Nej
The answer is B: No.
It appeared in the November 2025 exam.
[DA] ✔ B: Nej
Question 6.
Are Greenland and the Faroe Islands part of the EU?
Option A: Yes.
Option B: No.
[DA] Er Grønland og Færøerne en del af EU?  A: Ja  |  B: Nej
The answer is B: No.
It appeared in the November 2022 and May 2025 exams.
[DA] ✔ B: Nej
That's the end of this part.
Well done.